this video is sponsored by the great
courses plus get a free trial of their
on-demand video learning platform by
clicking the link in the description
after a horrible but in hindsight rather
obvious miscalculation
you've just been teleported some million
miles away from your intended position
placing you in the middle of
interstellar space right in the vicinity
of a black hole
you float helplessly because you were
just supposed to end up at a particular
space hub and the trip should have
otherwise been routine you mostly lack
anything of use for the situation other
than your enclosed spacesuit a
substantial amount of oxygen and a
high-capacity computer and contact
device you've been trying to coordinate
with your contact source in order to
provide them with your position with the
idea that the same as calculation could
be made again but this time
intentionally and with the rescue module
while you have been doing this the black
hole approaches you at an increasing
rate and you have had no way of
sufficiently turning yourself around and
moving in any other direction
after some more time passes a rescue
module and crew member have been
assembled and are in the process of
being sent to your location you feel a
moment of slight relief and hope as you
are notified of this which has quickly
brought further and further back down as
the black sphere of the outer region of
the black hole known as the event
horizon grows at a rate of change that
you can't barely even comprehend as you
approach at the universe and nearby
stars begin to diffract in strange ways
streaking and twisting as the gravity of
the black hole bends space-time more and
more causing light to orbit around it
and you your perception becomes
increasingly warped almost like the
universe is a fresh tube of toothpaste
and you are being squeezed out of it
soon the entire visible universe around
the black hole is pushed further and
further out of your field of view which
is by now mostly filled with the deathly
black of the indescribable void in front
of you
eventually the rescue module is sent to
your location but in order to ensure the
rescue members safety and avoid the risk
of already being too close to the black
hole it is sent a good distance back
away from your initial coordinates once
it arrives it approaches you from a
distance that now even from where you
were originally sent is a great length
away the rescue member and contact
dispatch members observe you through the
modules on board telescopic visual
recording device which is zoomed in on
you at about a hundred X plus
magnification the module is still much
too far away for you to see it at this
point as the gravitational force of the
black hole continues to contort
space time more and more the functions
of space and time are beginning to swap
we're now the direction of space becomes
singular and time becomes almost
multi-directional relative to the rescue
member and everyone else time has begun
to slow down immensely for you from
their perspective you are moving
incredibly slow nearly motionless and
suspended in space you dispatch in the
rescuer frantically contact back and
forth trying to determine the limits of
the situation in real time while real
time no longer has much of any meaning
it is by this point that it is basically
known by everyone but you that you had
mostly already been too close or nearly
past the event horizon of the black hole
by the time the module arrived and it is
too late for a rescue mission to be
safely completed with any real
probability by now you are mostly aware
of this as well you turn your head away
from the growing blackness in front of
you and look back towards the direction
you came looking for any sight of the
rescue module and an impulse of
remaining hope and desire to see anyone
before you never see anyone ever again
the observable universe behind you
appears to be speeding up in time
through that of a fisheye lens as the
warping black void begins to overtake it
more and more from your perspective the
space module flashes in and out of
existence before it can even be noticed
the universe speeds up and you see the
future rapidly unfold as you watch the
nothingness that has filled in front of
you begins to fill more and more behind
you and the black hole becomes less of a
hole than that of the rest of the entire
visible universe it looks almost as if
you are exiting out of a shrinking
rubber dome as the universe drifts into
the distance
narrowing tighter and tighter into an
increasingly tiny orb like glowing exit
door you have now completely left the
known universe the physics of space and
time as you understand them have lost
all relevance in operation from here
there is only one way in all directions
no matter what you do and where you go
everything around you approaching you is
the singularity of the black hole the
strange mysterious center that could be
the end or edge or breach of all
space-time the rescue member who has
since been instructed to abandon any
further approach observes you as you
appear to become
completely frozen in space on the outer
edge of the black hole the gravitational
force of the black hole had created a
dissonance of time and space so extreme
between you and the rest of the universe
that you appear to be completely frozen
in it from the perspective of the module
to everyone else
you haven't even disappeared yet even
though you are already somewhere inside
the rescue module has no choice but to
leave you there and what will sort of
remain like an infinitely suspended
death site from your perspective though
everything has continued and you float
inside the black hole for some amount of
time at some point you begin to
spaghettify or stretch as the
increasingly extreme difference of
gravities effects on your lower body
near as the singularity pull more than
it does on your upper body eventually
your disintegrated further and further
down all the way to your most minimal
and elementary particles you are in this
moment entirely theoretical of course no
one has and perhaps no one ever will be
in such a situation at least not without
it being some sort of science fiction or
distant future scenario thus we don't
really know what happens on the way in
or on the inside of a black hole one
because we can't physically access them
and two because based on what we do know
even if we could nothing could ever
enter survive and come back out to
confirm despite this though we do have
potentially fairly accurate mathematic
theoretical and computer-based models
that help us understand that if you were
in such a scenario it would maybe go
something like that although at least to
some extent the class and type of the
black hole could change many of the
related effects and occurrences of the
experience ultimately we can model and
predict these sorts of things but at a
certain point we obviously can't know
for sure we can and do however have a
decent sense of how black holes come to
form and work on the surface level which
is perhaps equally strange and
mysterious basically black holes form
when a disproportionately large amount
of matter is concentrated down into a
disproportionately small amount of space
theoretically anything with mass could
be turned into a black hole for at least
a brief period of time so long as the
objects mass was proportionally
condensed down enough which is to say
theoretically if compressed in such a
way you yourself could be turned into a
black hole however as far as we
and the only way black holes can
properly form and sustain themselves is
when a star of large enough mass much
greater than our own Sun dies and
collapses down under the force of its
own immense gravity the result of which
yields the most powerful strange and
mysterious thing in the known universe a
point that is known as the singularity
which is the point that sits at the
center of a black hole and causes all
the strange phenomena that occurs around
it this point is infinitely small
infinitely dense and causes gravity to
become infinitely great which then
results in an infinite curvature of
space-time the resulting gravitational
force becomes so immense that nothing
can escape it after crossing a certain
outer threshold layer of the black hole
known as the event horizon after
crossing this point no object or thing
in the entire universe can escape it not
even light however this is not
necessarily even the most perplexing
part about black holes rather perhaps
the most mysterious and perplexing part
is what happens from here the question
of where you or what was you ends up
going and what it might mean for our
understanding of physics and the nature
of everything
sometime after you would have passed the
event horizon and entered the black hole
not only would you break all the way
down to your most fundamental particles
but you and everything unique about you
the particular quantum information you
carry appears to potentially disappear
completely the information being
referred to here is not necessarily the
sort of information we might typically
think of but rather quantum information
that describes the properties of atoms
and the path of their various formal
arrangements which theoretically if you
hadn't been sucked into a black hole
would always continue to exist even
after you're gone and even more
theoretically if the information could
be collected and measured it would still
long into the future house and sustain
unique information about your physical
state this would be true for everything
across the entire history of the
universe in the case of falling into the
black hole though your information is
not only swallowed up but also
potentially erased we know this to be
possible because of a discovery made by
Stephen Hawking around 1974 which showed
that black holes emit radiation now
known as Hawking radiation and slowly
but surely over a very very incan
to be long time radiate their entire
mass away until they eventually in a
remote future die and dissolve away
completely this would then potentially
only leave their evaporated radiation
behind the problem here is that their
radiation seems to contain no unique
information but rather appears to be a
spewing of informational nothingness all
of it being the same as the rest
indistinguishable and impossible to
decipher anything from this is rather
terrifying just at face value what
becomes even more terrifying in terms of
what it means for physics and our
understanding of the universe the issue
here being a key principle of physics is
that no information in the universe can
ever be destroyed and if it is destroyed
much of what defines physics could be
wrong this issue is known as the black
hole information paradox there are a
number of ideas that attempt to resolve
this paradox some of which disregard or
refute the premise of Hawking's theory
some of which suggests the information
collects somewhere we can't quite find
or access either in or on the surface of
the black hole and it still remains
somewhere during and after a black holes
lifetime others of which suggests that
black holes create wormholes where
information is sent from this universe
to another universe or a different
position in space-time
all of which these and others
unmentioned currently remain highly
theoretical unprovable and unresolvable
ultimately the paradox of black holes
and the very nature of black holes is
one of if not the primary territories of
space that remains not only unknown but
essential to our understanding of
basically everything else even despite
the potential loss of quantum
information the very essence of our
current general understanding of black
holes defies physics and has serious
conflicting implications everything we
understand about the universe is
currently built on two pillars Albert
Einstein's theory of general relativity
and quantum mechanics Einstein's theory
of general relativity deals with a large
macro level of the universe and quantum
mechanics deals with the micro level
currently these two pillars work very
well on their own but don't often work
very well together and the unification
is generally accepted as one of science
and physics great contemporary issues
the accomplishment of which in the form
of some unifying equation would be
deemed potentially the theory of
everything
both of these pillars however appear to
find themselves in a rather strange
situation inside black holes where
neither seem to work based on Albert
Einstein's theory of general relativity
black holes create a singularity and
that's how we are able to form the
conclusion of it being there however
according to physics that's impossible
you can't have an infinite density or
infinite gravitational force or infinite
anything in physics infinity to our
knowledge cannot be real in a physical
measurable sense and when it appears in
equations it's essentially a sign of an
error or impossibility and thus
Einstein's theory breaks down at the
minut scale of the singularity typically
quantum field theory would step in but
quantum field theory can't work here
either because it can't yet explain
gravity and the functions of black holes
and the singularity are primarily based
on gravity and so it seems that
somewhere between the edge and core of
black holes as either the separate
collapse of both theories destroying
much of our understanding of everything
or the unification of both theories
creating a supposed ultimate theory of
everything in this sense the primary
answer needed for the complete
understanding of the universe happens to
potentially be contained in hidden
in a place that nothing can seemed to
ever enter and come out of a potential
final frontier of human knowledge
guarded by a mammoth sized galactic
beast perhaps this beast is undefeatable
or perhaps we simply lack the mathematic
weaponry to properly fight it in the
past for many of the greatest and most
confusing paradoxes in history even
greater Minds and greater efforts have
come along confronted and beat them
dissolving such paradoxes away into the
false cynical realm forever and perhaps
here inside black holes we will do the
same again
either that or perhaps we will be
dissolved by the paradox first you are
in this moment elementary particles
traveling closer and closer to the
singularity of the black hole you
entered some irrelevant time ago
the quantum informational revenants of
you remains as it circulates in a way
that could only be described beyond
material perception eventually it
locates inside on the outside or
somewhere beyond the black hole your
material collects together or spews and
scatters everywhere it makes no
difference
you exist here at this particular point
at the answer your particles reveal what
hundreds of thousands of years of
civilization has labored to discover an
embodiment of space-time matter energy
and features of reality unknown an
unveiling of the limits of the infinite
and the unending succeeding conformal
boundaries of the finite an explanation
of everything and you are particles
[Music]
this video was sponsored by the great
courses plus sustaining curiosity and
lifelong education is not only important
in life from a practical perspective but
is perhaps also essential for an
interesting and enjoyable life as well
and finding helpful clever ways of doing
this can be of great value the great
courses plus is a subscription on-demand
video learning platform that provides
over 11,000 lectures in a variety of
subjects related to science philosophy
health literature arts personal
development and much more making
learning on your own terms
easy and accessible with content
provided by professors from Ivy League's
and top universities around the world as
well as experts from places like
National Geographic and the Smithsonian
courses are reliable easy to understand
comprehensive and at the cutting edge if
you're interested in learning more about
theories principles and current
mysteries and physics one course worth
checking out is entitled the theory of
everything the quest to explain all
reality the courses taught by senior
scientist and professor Don Lincoln who
provides a comprehensive overview of
topics related to gravity space-time
light quantum particles dark energy and
much more ultimately showcasing what
these features implicate in terms of
possibilities for how what and why
reality might be and the ways we were
attempting to resolve their remaining
mysteries into one cohesive origin story
you can start your free trial of the
great courses plus today by visiting the
great courses plus comm slash pursuit of
wonder or by clicking the link in the
description below of course thanks so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
[Music]
you